so over the weekend President Donald
Trump sent out some tweets that were so
outrageous so unhinged and delusional so
indicative of really a total
disconnection from the real world that
they make all of his previous tweets and
statements seem quite frankly not that
bad and of course you'll you'll you'll
realize that that's a contrast that
really tells us this new material is
just stunning and before I show you the
tweets I'll remind you that all of this
seems to relate to this new book from
Michael Wolfe Michael Wolfe put out a
book just a few days ago about the Trump
administration it's called fire and fury
and the book has made Trump and his
administration completely panic to try
to get it written off as fake news as
lies as fiction even though Michael
Wolfe continues to say that he stands
behind the book 100 percent in terms of
accurately publishing what people he
interviewed told him of course those
people could have been lying but Michael
Wolfe is saying no this is this includes
completely accurately the interviews
that I had with people in and around the
Trump administration and the book is
based around several hundred interviews
including allegedly as far as Michael
Wolfe says an interview with Trump
himself Trump though is denying that
that interview ever took place that's
sort of a basic factor I did either the
interview took place or it didn't and
it's very difficult for me to believe
that Michael Wolfe would just make up
the fact that he had an interview with
Donald Trump when he didn't but needless
to say a lot of the material in the book
is based around this idea that Trump is
just not with it that he's not competent
that he's experiencing cognitive decline
of the type of the type that we often
see with various forms of dementia this
includes not recognizing people people
he's known for a long time lots of other
stuff and we'll talk more about the
details in another segment but this has
clearly rattled Donald Trump so much
that Saturday morning over the weekend
Donald Trump sent out a couple of tweets
basically making the case that he's both
genius-level smart and also very very
stable the most stable president we've
ever had not something you really want
your leader arguing on the Internet
right let's go through the tweet tweet
starting with the first one where Trump
said now that Russian collusion after
one year of intense study has been
proven to be a total hoax that's not
true nothing's been proven to be a hoax
about Russian collusion on the American
public the Democrats and their lapdogs
the fake news mainstream media are
taking out the old ronald reagan
playbook and screaming mental stability
and intelligence going on to say in the
second tweet actually throughout my life
my two greatest assets have been mental
stability and being like really smart
crooked Hillary Clinton also played
these cards very hard and as everyone
knows went down in flames
I went from very successful businessmen
to top TV star to President of the
United States on my first try I think
that would qualify as not smart but
genius and a very stable genius at that
as soon as Saturday morning I woke up
and I saw I'm like a smart person I
thought no no that that's got to be a
parody because of course it relates back
to the time Trump said that on Fox News
Sunday remember this you are getting the
presidential Daily Brief
that's only once a week well I get it
when I need it I don't have to be told
you know I'm like a smart person I'm
like a smart person I thought for sure
that this was satire but no Donald Trump
again saying I am like a smart person
and of course I'm really stable really
trust me does not exactly communicate
stability on the behalf of a president
right when you are the president and
you're sending out tweets trying to
convince people that you are both
mentally smart and stable you've kind of
already lost right and the other odd
thing is that in his first tweet Trump
said this is the old Ronald Reagan
playbook questioning the mental fitness
of Trump is like people who questioned
Ronald Reagan's mental fitness we later
learned that Reagan had Alzheimer's
during the presidency if this is
anything like when people were
questioning whether Reagan was fit to
serve that means from
needs to be removed now yeah that would
be like him trying to defend himself in
the Russia probe by saying that the
media tried to take down Richard Nixon
when it came to Watergate right it's a
worthy comparison but not one that
really defends him
no no it's one that incriminates him and
it's also not true that Donald Trump won
the presidency on his first try he ran
in the year 2000 on the Reform Party I'm
actually having a hard time finding
anything in these tweets that's true
imagine for a moment what would have
happened if President Obama had tweeted
about being of sound mind guys really
I'm not demented I'm smart it would have
been wall-to-wall 24/7 immediate calls
for resignation and impeachment from the
right and Sarah Huckabee Sanders is now
I don't know if I can call it on the
defensive but she's panicking and once
again when the president of the United
States is defending his mental stability
that's bad when the focus in
interviewing a press secretary becomes
the president's own defenses of his
mental stability that's really bad and
she went on Fox and Friends over the
weekend and said what's really mentally
unstable as people that don't see the
positive impact that this president is
having on the country tell me more Sarah
I'd love to hear more about that how is
no one controlling Trump right it's
clear now that no one apparently can
control the guy because this is
completely self destructed it
destructive and Trump may be sort of
some combination of delusional and
narcissistic in that he might think hey
if I just start tweeting about how smart
and stable I am I'll convince people
instead of realizing that it actually
makes him seem even less credible
because these tweets along with
everything else are really starting to
put pressure on Congress as well as on
Donald Trump's cabinet in the context of
the 25th amendment to really put aside
political positions put aside Trump's
lack of political experience put all of
that stuff aside just based on cognitive
ability it's unclear that this man is
fit to be President of the United States
yeah and this is the sort of thing that
you can kind of just brush under the rug
you don't have to defend yourself really
from these allegations because that's
president you can pick and choose your
battles and no matter how you choose to
defend yourself against allegations that
you're unstable it's not going to look
well no any
you start saying I'm really smart and
stable and there's nothing to see here
it only calls more attention to it
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership